für wen ist das paket
das paket ist für sie
das paket ist für dich
das paket ist für mich
für welche partei stimmst du
ich stimme für
grünen
ich stimme für die
lünen
für welches team bist du
ich bin für das blaue team
für welche mannschaft bist du
für welche mannschaft bist du ich bin
für die mannschaft mit den blauen
trikots
ich bin für die mannschaft mit den
blauen trikots
gegen wen spielt der fc bayern morgen
gegen
spielt der fc bayern morgen
er spielt gegen den fc barcelona
gegen welches gesetz habe ich verstoßen
sie sind zu schnell gefahren
ohne mein handy gehe ich nie aus dem
haus ohne mein handy gehe ich nie aus
dem haus
ohne benzin fährt mein auto nicht
ohne deine hilfe hätte ich das nie
geschafft ohne deine hilfe hätte ich das
nie geschafft
ich kann ohne schokolade nicht leben
das auto fährt durch den tunnel
das auto fährt durch den tunnel die
katze rennt durch den garten
die katze rennt durch den garten
durch den unfall ist eine person
umgekommen
viele menschen sind durch die krankheit
angesteckt worden
mit wem triffst du dich mit wem triffst
du dich
ich treffe mich mit meinen freunden
ich treffe mich mit meiner kollegin ich
treffe mich mit meiner kollegin
mit wem streites du mit wem streitet du
ich streite mit meinem freund
ich streite mit meiner frau ich streite
mit meiner frau
von wem ist diese e-mail von wem ist
diese e-mail
die e mail ist von meiner schwester die
e mail ist von meiner schwester
[Musik]
die e mail ist von meinen eltern die e
mail ist von meinen eltern
bei wem war
du bei wem warst du
ich war bei hans ich war bei hans
ich war bei den nachbarn ich war bei den
nachbarn
ich war beim arzt
ich war bei der friseurin
ich war bei der frisörin zu wem gehst du
zu wem gehst du ich gehe zu ärztin
ich gehe zur ärztin
ich gehe zum anwalt ich gehe zum anwalt
ich gehe zu oliver ich gehe zu oliver
ich gehe zu meinen freunden ich gehe zu
meinen freunden
aus welchem kann
und kommst du
aus welchem kanton kommst du
ich komme aus dem kanton graubünden
[Musik]
aus welchem bundesland kommst du aus
welchem bundesland kommst du
ich komme aus dem bundesland bayern
[Musik]
seit wann lebst du in deutschland seit
wann lebst du in deutschland
ich wohne seit einem jahr in deutschland
ich wohne seit drei jahren in
deutschland ich wohne seit drei jahren
in deutschland ich wohne seit sechs
monaten in deutschland
ich wohne seit sechs monaten in
deutschland
ich wohne seit einem halben jahr in
deutschland ich wohne seit einem halben
jahr in deutschland ich wohne seit
eineinhalb jahren in deutschland ich
wohne seit eineinhalb jahren in
deutschland
mein haus steht gegenüber von der kirche
mein haus steht gegenüber von dem
fitnesscenter mein haus steht gegenüber
von dem fitnesscenter mein haus steht
gegenüber von dem supermarkt mein haus
steht gegenüber von dem supermarkt
ich esse einen apfel
ich esse einen apfel ruf mich bitte
anrufen
ich bitte an gib mir den schlüssel
[Musik]
gib mir den schlüssel
wer bist du wer bist du ich kenne dich
ich kenne dich wir helfen dir wir helfen
dir das ist hanspeter das
ist hanspeter er geht die den gleichen
deutschkurs wie ich er geht in den
gleichen deutschkurs wie ich kennst du
ihn
kennst du ihn ich stelle dich ihm vor
ich stelle dich ihm vor das ist ronja
das ist ronja sie ist meine patentochter
sie ist meine patentochter das
schenk ist für sie das geschenk ist für
sie
ich schenke ihr etwas zum geburtstag ich
schenke ihr etwas zum geburtstag
das sind die personalpronomen im domina
tief akkusativ dativ ich mich mir
du dich dir er ihm sie sie ihr wir uns
uns ihr euch euch sie ihnen
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video